- Is it true that you
used to be really shy,
that you used to give your
mom notes and not tell her?
You would just give her
notes and not talk about it?
- Yeah, I-
- This is funny.
- I was so shy.
I had a hard time sort of
expressing my needs or my desires,
and my mom, who was the best mom ever,
used to leave me little notes
on my pillow at night
just saying, "I love you,"
or you know, "Good job today at school."
And so I thought,
"Oh, well that's a way that
I can get what I want"-
- Communicate.
- Without speaking to you.
So, I used to slip things
in under her door at night.
You know, "I really want
that Barbie" or whatever,
and then it became sort
of more complicated.
Like when I turned, I think, nine,
I would write, "I really want an agent,"
and...
(audience laughs)
She was kind of like,
"I have no idea how to get you an agent,
but that's really cute."
- Yeah, you knew that young.
That's incredible.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Not everybody has that,
knows that.
- Well, didn't you
know young that you-
- Not at nine, no, no.
I sang in church like every
other human in my community,
so it wasn't special,
so I didn't, no, I didn't know till I was,
I don't know, like teens?
- Yeah.
- No, I do think it's lucky
to know at a young age.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, for sure.
- A lot of people will
go through their life
and they're a jack of all
trade but master of not one
that they really focus on that they love,
so it's cool, and that
we find that that young.
- Yeah, I feel lucky that
I love it as much today
as I did then, you know?
- Yeah, oh, that's special.
- I know.
- I feel like when that goes,
people always ask me like,
"Do you think you'll ever retire?"
And I'm like, "Whenever I'm tired of it
or if it gets boring."
- Yeah. Yeah.
- But I still love it, so, yeah, yeah.